i
[Música]
ah
venezuela que comenzó hace un par de
semanas a inmunizar contra kobe 19
utilizando la vacuna cubana abdalá
recibió un primer cargamento con 30.000
dosis donadas el mes pasado aún cuando
el fármaco no había sido aprobado
siquiera por el ente regulador de la
isla principal aliado internacional del
gobierno a nicolás maduro esta cantidad
fue suficiente para inmunizar a 10.000
personas según la información que dio la
misión cubana en este país su uso en
venezuela trajo numerosas críticas por
parte del gremio venezolano de la salud
que ha que se inmunice a la
población como una vacuna aún en pruebas
en fuerte tiuna el principal complejo
militar de caracas el gobierno junto a
la misión cubana abría un centro de
inmunización donde la única disponible
era la cubana abdalá en este centro de
vacunación contra la cob y 19 no había
fila de personas ni tampoco era
necesario recibir un turno asignado por
mensaje de texto como si ocurre en otros
puntos donde se ofrece la vacuna china y
la rusa que hoy está sea para la segunda
dosis en este país el gobierno de maduro
ya tiene un contrato con la habana para
la compra de 12 millones de dosis de la
gala que podría estar llegando baratas
en los próximos meses
[Música]
a fines de mayo una comitiva encabezada
por la ministra de salud argentina carla
vizzotti visitó cuba para conocer
detalles sobre las vacunas contra kobe
19 que se desarrollan en ese país
incluida la vacuna abdalá en ese momento
la ministra dijo que argentina estaba
trabajando para acceder a la vacuna pero
también entre otras cosas para colaborar
en la posible expansión de su producción
dijo además que se firmó un convenio de
confidencialidad que suele ser un paso
previo en las negociaciones de compra y
que el intercambio de información entre
los organismos reguladores de
medicamentos de ambos países hasta ahora
en argentina se están utilizando las
vacunas public vecino farm y astrazéneca
y tras un reciente cambio la normativa
vigente que permitió destrabar la
negociación con otro conjunto de
laboratorios el país firmó un acuerdo
con modernas por 20 millones de dosis
que deberían llegar en el primer
trimestre del próximo año
[Música]
en bolivia la gobernación de potosí que
está administrada por el partido
oficialista movimiento al socialismo ha
anunciado la compra de la vacuna cubana
abra la para inmunizar a niños y jóvenes
comprendidos entre los 10 y los 18 años
el gobierno de luisa se ha anunciado su
apoyo a esta iniciativa mediante el
ministerio de salud y próximamente se
harán reuniones para ultimar los
detalles de esta adquisición quienes no
están de acuerdo son los médicos
potosinos del colegio profesional de
este gremio ha dicho que la población de
ese departamento no puede ser un
conejillo de indias pues la vacuna
abdalá todavía se encuentra en la fase 3
de ensayos clínicos entretanto en
bolivia avanza la vacunación masiva con
otras marcas por ejemplo con scinopharm
de china y acaba de arribar al país un
lote de un millón de vacunas de johnson
y johnson de la iniciativa kóvacs
[Música]